could humans really migrate to Mars
first we need to warm things up a bit
hence World War I Mars
Edition NASA's perseverance Rover has
already successfully converted Martian
CO2 into oxygen we'll need to detox the
soil but NASA has already grown healthy
plants in simulated Martian soil so it's
theoretically possible we'd have to
import nitrogen on a massive scale
another option would be unleashing
oxygen producing
microorganisms to slowly increase O2
levels we could go for a slightly more
ambitious approach and simply build
artificial habitats on or possibly
beneath the Martian surface in fact Elon
Musk already has plans to build a fully
functioning Mars City with up to a
million inhabitants by 2050 could human
beings really travel to and eventually
colonize the red planet your guess is as
good as mine